ja willkommen zu einer neuen Folge bei
fidocast wir haben schon
folgen über Bitcoin blockchain und
metavers gemacht das ist ja alles oben
verlinkt und heute sprechen wir über
künstliche Intelligenz englischsprachig
ai mit Jörg Noller der sich damit seit
2019 intensiv beschäftigt und genau die
erste Frage wäre natürlich hier ganz
prominent wie funktioniert bevor wir zu
den Gesellschaft philosophischen Themen
kommen wie funktioniert was was was
können wir uns darunter vorstellen ja
erstmal hallo Marcel vielen Dank für die
Einladung ja künstlichen Intelligenz
häufig auch genauer gesagt maschinelles
Lernen ist eine neue Form von
Datenverarbeitung die Zeit einigen
Jahren besonders an Interesse gewinnt
aus philosophische Perspektive wir
kennen das vielleicht noch von Deep Blue
das war ein Schachcomputer der hat gegen
Gary Casper auf den Weltmeister damals
gewonnen das war wirklich ein
eine wirkliche Überraschung gewesen das
war damals noch die symbolverarbeitende
künstlichen Intelligenz die eher so mit
logischen Schlüssen operiert hat seit
einigen Jahren gibt es eine andere Form
von künstliche Intelligenz die wird dann
maschinelles Lernen genannt und da geht
es nicht so sehr von oben nach unten
also von logischen Gesetzen zu konkreten
Schlüssen und Ableitungen sondern da ist
das ganze Verfahren eher andersrum
nämlich von unten nach oben also
empirisch kann man sagen auch schon das
Wort lernen zeigt an das System das
probiert da ein bisschen was aus Trial
and Error es gibt immer wieder so
Feedback Schleifen also wenn das System
sich praktisch geirrt hat dann wird es
wieder korrigiert das korrigiert sich
selbst und das ganze findet auf einer
gewaltigen Datenbasis statt und das ist
so gewissermaßen des empirische daran
ohne eine Datenbasis ohne einen leeren
Umfeld kann dieses System gar nichts
lernen das heißt dieses System Maschine
lässt lernen dass versucht
aus einer Datenbasis Gesetze heraus zu
abstrahieren durch permanenten versuchen
Irrtum und am Ende ist dieses System
ziemlich gut eingespielt so dass es am
Ende musste erkennen kann und zwar muss
der ganz verschiedene Art im
medizinischen Bereich wenn es um
Krankheiten geht aber auch wenn zum
Spracherkennung geht das heißt wir
können uns eigentlich unsere gesamte
Lebenswelt als als Zusammenhang von
Mustern vorstellen und je nach Muster
können wir auch prinzipiell eine
künstlichen Intelligenz trainieren die
diese musste erkennen
da komme ich gleich zur Zwang zum
Beispiel dieser Anwendungsfälle und
ich habe mich halt bei deepl diesen
Übersetzungsprogramm gefragt oder was
mir halt aufgefallen dass es viel besser
ist als Google Translator die Frage für
mich war immer so warum und was ich so
ein bisschen gelesen habe war das deepel
keine Grammatik lernt die also keine
Regeln sondern eigentlich wie ein Kind
einfach an einem Haufen Batzen an
Sprache ausgesetzt ist und durch
probieren wie du es gerade erklärt hast
dann immer besser wird und wäre das so
ein Beispiel eigentlich wo man diesen
Unterschied erkennt dann die die Wendung
von lernen legt nahe das ist eine
gewisse Parallele zu menschlichen Lehren
gibt hier muss man natürlich immer ein
bisschen aufpassen auch die Struktur von
künstlichen neuronalen Netzen so spricht
man häufig auch wenn man mit Blick auf
maschinelles Lernen spricht die ist nur
recht rudimentär die menschlichen Gehirn
nachgebildet alles gibt Vorbilder
nämlich Synapsen und die werden im
modelliert am Ende ist der Prozess doch
recht verschieden aber prinzipiell wenn
man es ganz basal fast denke ich schon
dass man es auch mit einem kindlichen
deren vergleichen kann einfach deswegen
weil das Kind ja auch nicht die Regel
eingespeichert hat das Kind lernt ja
auch nicht die Satz Regeln die Grammatik
Regeln und erweitern dann sein
Sprachvermögen einzelne ist versucht
einfach was es sagt etwas heraus und
dann wird es korrigiert von seinem
Umfeld und so lernt immer wieder Trial
and Error man spricht häufig auch von
evolutionärer KI das ist einfach auch
dieses Prinzip trial and era immer
wieder versuchen und zwar eben sehr
häufig versuchen auf einer großen
Datenbasis versuchen und am Ende hat
sich das System eingespielt und das
sieht man eben sehr gut bei Deep er du
hast schon darauf hingewiesen die
Ergebnisse sind beeindruckend was dieses
System vermag so mag wirklich auch
sprachliche Feinheiten auszudrücken die
andere Programme meines Wissens gar
nicht konnten natürlich hat auch dieses
System Grenzen wenn man vielleicht
versucht ironisch oder doppeldeutige
Dinge zu übersetzen vielleicht hat
dieses Thema noch nicht wirklich ein
musste Erkennungsverfahren für Ironie
entwickelt aber auch das ist ja
eigentlich etwas was auf gewissen
Gesetzen passiert und auch diese kann
man durchfallen error dem System ein
Lernen gewissermaßen also ich sehe da
sehr viele Möglichkeiten auch noch
sprachliche Feinheiten weiter zu
entwickeln bei deepl aber es ist ja
schon so dass auch jetzt bei visuellen
Beispielen wie der Frage ist es ein
Muffin oder ein Hundewelpe dass er so
die AI weiß ja gar nicht also sie weiß
ja nicht was jetzt ein Hund ist und was
Muffin ist sondern genau und da habe ich
mich immer gefragt
du sprichst von lernen die lernt dann
und Trial and Error aber wer ist die
Instanz die das Richtig und Falsch
dieser schreibt sind wir Menschen das
dann mit Klicks oder ja also ich denke
du sprichst auch nicht dieses Thema an
das ist das Thema der Mensch Maschine
Interaktion wir reden häufig auch in
philosophischen Kontexten recht ja
vorschnell davon dass die KI irgendetwas
kann irgendetwas tun sie erkennt was sie
lernt was sie weiß was sie versucht was
das sind natürlich alles andere pro
morphisieren die Rede weißen so wie wir
häufig auch von unbeliebten Gegenständen
zu tun als seien die irgendwie Mensch
wir haben auch die Tendenz nicht
menschliche Tiere menschliche
Eigenschaften hineinzuprojizieren und
das passiert gerade sehr häufig auch bei
künstlichen Intelligenz natürlich
versteht künstliche Intelligenz nicht es
hat keinen Sinn von Bedeutung es ist ja
kein Lebewesen ne was künstliche
Intelligenz kann es einfach zuverlässig
zu erkennen ich würde schon sagen das
ist eine gewisse detektorische Funktion
hat aber es hat kein Bewusstsein von
diesem entdecken und es hat auch keine
Qualia also irgendwelche roteindrücke
keine Stimmungen keine Gefühle das kann
das System nicht aber es kann sehr gut
einen Zweck erfüllen einen Zweck den wir
dem System von außen natürlich ist geben
müssen von selbst aus wird es ein
KI-System nie sich ein eigenes wegsetzen
würde ich jetzt mal behaupten deswegen
ist es auch keine Personen kein freies
Wesen
ja und und und und und was wie ist deine
Haltung zu diesem Konzept von
Singularität also diesen Moment wo eh
oder die ganze Welt der Maschinen und
Computer eins wird und die
Weltherrschaft übernimmt so ist es
jedenfalls wie ich es im Hinterkopf
haben glaubst du hättest du sowas für
realistisch und welche Form würde das
haben diese dieser Moment diesen genau
dieser Moment in der Gesellschaft wie
wie wie könnten wir woran würden wir es
festmachen glaubst du du sprichst auch
wieder ein wichtiges Thema an Thema
Singularität das ist ein Begriff von Ray
Kurzweil einem kalifornischen Ingenieur
einem sehr begnadeten Ingenieur der aber
auch dann ein bisschen Science Fiction
Spekulation betrieben hat in seinem Buch
das singularity ist mir
singularity meint einen fernen Zeitpunkt
vielleicht in 100 Jahren so ungefähr im
Jahr
2200 irgendwie sowas zu dem
in dem die technische Entwicklung so
rapide exponentiell angestiegen ist dass
Maschinen Selbstbewusstsein entwickeln
also dass sie praktisch Fähigkeiten
kognitive Fähigkeiten besitzen die wir
Menschen auch besitzen und zwar in noch
viel höherem Maße momentan reden viele
davon dass künstlichen Intelligenzen nur
menschliche Fähigkeiten simulieren aber
nicht realisieren und die Singularität
wäre der Zeitpunkt der Moment wo die
Maschinen nicht mehr nur simulieren
sondern wirklich realisieren und das ist
natürlich hochspekulativ weil es
passiert einfach auf eine Prognose also
kurz weil zieht gewissermaßen eine
exponentielle Linie weiter in die
Zukunft extrapoliert und schließt dann
das an irgendeinem Zeitpunkt wenn die
Kurve steige genug ist die Rechenpower
pro Sekunde so extrem hoch ist dass dann
das neues Energien muss gewissermaßen
aus dem aus dem Moment heraus und so ein
Moment zu beschreiben zu begründen
philosophisch kaum möglich man kann
natürlich sich immer beziehen auf das
menschliche Gehirn kann sagen wenn eine
gewisse Dichte und Anzahl von neuronalen
Phänomenen von Prozessen stattfindet
dann Energie auch Selbstbewusstsein das
ist ja bei uns Menschen der Fall und das
ist bei
Kakerlaken wahrscheinlich nicht der Fall
dass die Selbstbewusstsein haben das
heißt es muss schon irgendwie mit der
Dichte und der Packung zu tun haben aber
diese Übertragung auf die Technologie
scheint mir ein bisschen ja gewagt zu
sein also ich bin hier ein bisschen
skeptisch was Singularitäten in der
Zukunft anbelangt okay ähm mein
Kommentar dazu wäre naja also was ich
schon spannend finde ist dass wir oft
dann auch
so diese Verbindung von Menschen und
Maschine irgendwie
utopisch irgendwann in der Zukunft und
eigentlich für unmöglich halten und
gleichzeitig gibt es aber Phänomene in
unserer Gesellschaft wo ich den Eindruck
bekomme dass wir eigentlich schon
ziemlich nah dran sind vielleicht ist
auch diese menschenmaschine Verbindungen
eine falsche Beschreibung vielleicht
sogar sowas wie Augmented Reality eine
bessere Beschreibung dafür und zwar
wollte ich damit ähm hindeuten will ist
die also genau wir leben eigentlich
schon in einer Welt wo das digitale und
das analoge ineinander miteinander
verbunden sind und zwar so verbunden
dass es äh die virtuelle Welt ein schon
realen Charakter bekommen hat Beispiele
sind für mich immer ganz prominent und
wichtig die Tatsache dass Social Media
Posts auf Twitter und also in diesem
Internet
total fern in irgendeiner klaut
irgendwelche Kommentare dass die einen
Einfluss darauf hatten wie in also wie
gewählt wird also ein realpolitischen
Einfluss so das ist nachzuweisen die
ganze Cambridge analytica Thematik ist
ja also ist genau das Thema aber auch
das Center for you Main technology macht
ganz viel research zu dieser Frage
inwiefern hat Technologie schon einen
Einfluss auf unser echtes Leben und
können wir Technologie und unter anderem
auch Social Media Technologie
Kommunikationstechnologie menschlich
also human gestalten das ist ein super
spannendes Projekt und ähm die machen da
ganz viel research darüber und ich habe
den ein und die haben auch Recht damit
wenn man sagt na ja es hat er es führt
ja zu echten Handlungen also das was
online passiert führt zu echten
Handlungen ähm genau also ich finde
deine
Theorie sehr überzeugend nicht nur von
Mensch Maschine Interaktion zu sprechen
weil es häufig dann auch so die Ansicht
nahegelegt die künstlichen Intelligenz
ist nur sage ich mal so ein Instruments
und Werkzeug was wir da so gebrauchen
können Interaktion müssen wir stärker
verstehen und vielleicht noch stärker
vom Menschen her denken der Mensch
benutzt die Technologie die digitale
nicht nur als Instrument sondern er
erweitert du hast auch gesagt Augmented
Reality erweitert seine Erkenntnis und
nicht nur seine Erkenntnis sondern
erweitert den Raum der Realität es
entstehen neue Räume du hast den Begriff
schon genannt virtuelle Räume das
Internet gerade auch Thema Metaversum da
haben meine Sendung dazu gemacht ist ja
nicht nur so ein simulationsraum nicht
nur einen Spielplatz
sondern es ist ein virtueller
Handlungsraum das was dort stattfindet
hat realen Gehalt das sind Handlungen
die wir vollziehen und nicht nur
irgendwelche Spieler rein und die
künstliche Intelligenz und auch
überhaupt die Technologie der
digitalisieren erlaubt es uns solche
Räume indem wir uns auf neu Weise auch
realisieren können vielleicht dazu
erzeugen
und auch durch die Raum und zeitlogik
ist unterliegt ja dort nichts der
Reibung der physischen Reibung alles
geleitet dorthin wie Luciano floridi wie
ich finde es ja zutreffend gesagt hat er
hat von einer Reibungslosigkeit
gesprochen der digitalen infosphäre
durch diese Bedingungen diese
raumzeitliche Logik des virtuellen
Raumes können wir viele Dinge ganz
leichter realisieren als wir es im
herkömmlichen Leben tun Kommunikation
ist so ein Thema
grenzüberschreitende Interaktion ist so
ein Thema da gibt's sehr viele
Möglichkeiten
und und jetzt vielleicht noch den Kreis
zu schließen bei dieser Frage nach der
Zukunft von dem ganzen ai so
also ich würde auch fast behaupten also
das ist so meine mein meine Prognose
meine Vermutung für die Zukunft dass
diese
Verbindung von AI und Mensch Interaktion
angeht ich es kann halt sein dass wir in
dass wir das gar nicht bemerken also die
Frage diese Szenario oder Singularität
wird immer oft so dargestellt wie ähm
dann ist es eindeutig wie die Maschinen
übernehmen also Matrix ist auch zum
Beispiel dafür
ganz klar einfach dann ähm ja wo wo wo
wo wo wo die Maschine also wirklich so
die Menschen Welt übernimmt und
Matrix finde ich es intelligent gemacht
weil die ja dann noch mal diese
simulationswelt haben in der Menschen ja
dann wirklich nicht bemerken dass sie in
irgendeiner neuen Welt sind und den
Aspekt würde ich auch unterschreiben
einfach aus dem Grund weil wir jetzt
schon merken und das meine ich also die
Tatsache dass unser Weltbild unsere Welt
anschauen so massiv schon geprägt das
von Social Media das ist eine Prämisse
die viele gar nicht ernst nehmen
heutzutage Tage ich habe das Gefühl dass
so immer gesagt wird naja wir wissen ja
eh alles das ist ja alles klar also
steht ja alles online in den Nachrichten
und gleichzeitig merke ich aber nee nee
wie wir sind schon seit fünf Jahren
mindestens und wenn ich sogar zehn
Jahren Informationen ausgesetzt von
allen Seiten auf verschiedene Arten mit
verschiedenen Quellen wir sind schon
längst in der Welt wo wir gar nicht
bemerken was für einen großen Einfluss
Social Media Technologie auf auf unserer
Weltwahrnehmung hat also in gewisser
Weise haben wir schon Aspekte von
Simulationen in dem Sinn und deswegen
wäre meine Vermutung für die Zukunft
wenn es irgendwann mal dazu kommen würde
dann dann wäre die Chance hoch dass wir
das gar nicht bemerken dass wir dass wir
an den Punkt sind wo ähm Computer sich
selbstständig haben so vielleicht
kommunizieren die schon und wir müssen
es aber nicht z.B das wäre ja auch eine
Möglichkeit ist durchaus möglich ich bin
da noch skeptisch natürlich
kommunizieren sie im Sinne von
Smartphones
ähm all der Kühlschrank kommuniziert mit
meinem Smartphone und das kommuniziert
in Zukunft mit meiner Waage und wir
kennen alles Beispiel wenn ich zu viel
wiege dann geht der Kühlschrank nicht
mehr auf weil im Gesundheits Algorithmus
dazu gekommen ist das zu verbieten das
ist alles möglich aber den anderen Punkt
finde ich sehr spannend sehr zutreffen
den du erwähnt hast diese Singularität
sollten wir viel schwächer verstehen und
zwar auch nicht so sehr etwas was in der
Zukunft legt oder was so eine
vertikale Logik suggeriert dass da
irgendwas Energie hat oder etwas eine
macht eine Ohren ein Monster oder wie
eine Gefahr entsteht sondern die die die
Bedeutung der Digitalisierung die haben
macht sich in unserem alltäglichen Leben
fast unmerklich bemerkbar wenn man so
sagen kann ist ein bisschen
widersprüchlich aber sie trinkt einen
alle möglichen Lebensprozesse und
erleichtert diese Lebensprozesse und sie
ist so angenehm und reibungslos dass sie
gar nicht mehr bemerken wir können aber
eigentlich nicht mehr ohne sie wirklich
leben schon fast ja weil einfach diese
Annehmlichkeit so groß ist die
Reibungslosigkeit die überall
Verfügbarkeit die ubi Präsenz von
digitalen Informationen das heißt die
Revolution die Singularität hat schon
längst stattgefunden könnte man pontiert
sagen nur es ist so alltäglich und
lebenswertlich geschmeidig dass wir da
keine Angst davor entwickeln müssen da
sie nichts bedeuten wie eine fremde
Macht sind Strukturen es sind keine
Subjekte die entstehen sind Strukturen
die in unseren Alltag eingehen und den
prägen und verändern und zwar sehr auf
eine sehr angenehme gar nicht so brutal
revolutionäre Art das wäre so mein
Versuch das ein bisschen
herunterzustufen diese Angst ja
ja und du dieses unmerkliche
zeigt sich glaube ich hier gerade also
oder so also gerade vor eineinhalb
Monaten haben wir staple die Fusion
bekommen das ist ja diese Open Source
Software oder oder dieser Algorithmus
der es schafft auf eine unglaublich
überzeugende Art und Weise egal ob es
mit Text oder bildbefehlen sind Bilder
zu erzeugen das heißt ich kann
eigentlich sowas schreiben wie
ja eine das habe ich ja eh gemacht deine
Pariser Bäckerei während der Steampunk
Zeit in Paris
während eines Sonnenuntergangs so in der
Art habe ich ja einen Befehl
aufgeschrieben und die AI die ich
benutzt habe in dem Fall war es mit
journey ist der Name also ein Anbieter
der dieses stability Fusion Technologie
verkauft und benutzt und nutzbar macht
das hat dann das Bild hier
produziert und es ist einfach on point
einfach das Bild was ich haben wollte es
war vielleicht nicht im Detail so exakt
so ich habe es mir nicht genauso
vorgestellt aber aber die Atmosphäre und
das was dargestellt wurde hat die
perfekt getroffen und und das ist jetzt
gerade noch ein total disruptiver Moment
es gibt mit derselben ai wurde ein
Kunstpreis gewonnen ähm der Künstler hat
halt gegen andere Künstler gewonnen die
halt per Hand gemalt haben er hat die
verwendet und dann eine eigene
Komposition aus verschiedenen
aia-ergebnisse gestaltet und und viele
finden das total unfair regen sich
drüber auf und sind total ganz Bach also
gerade in so cool momentan erlebt man
wie auch wahrscheinlich damals mit dem
Schach Roboter diesen disruptiven Moment
und dann ist es irgendwie unmerklich
Standard normal alle wissen dann kann
der Praktikant auf einmal für eine
Filmproduktion des Konzept Art machen
und einfach mal eine Herr der
ringe-landschaft innerhalb von 30
Sekunden produzieren indem er einfach
schreibt Lord of the Rings mountain
landscape und ja also ja also ich finde
man sieht es beeindruckend gerade an
solchen kreativen Bereichen wo auch
Mensch Maschinen Interaktionen
ästhetischer Hinsicht eine ganz neue
Bedeutung bekommt also wir können uns
wirklich auch inspirieren lassen
plötzlich von diesen
Algorithmen was ich hier noch spannend
finde ist dass die ja auch nicht das
ganze erfinden gewissermaßen sind sie
greifen die Algorithmen die Kies die
greifen auf eine Datenbasis zurück auf
eine ganz gewaltige bilddatenbasis die
natürlich auch quasifiziert sein muss
und so weiter und das möchte noch
betonen wir Menschen sind soll in
solchen kreativen Prozessen immer auch
Teil wir sind beteiligt weil wir zu der
Daten warte Basis beitragen genauso wie
wir auch zu der sprachlichen Datenbasis
beitragen auf der die operiert das
möchte ich immer ein bisschen betonen
also wir sind nicht so etwas was
entfernt ist von der KI also hier der
Mensch hier die KI sind wir bieten der
KI gewissermaßen die Basis und gehen
deswegen immer ein in die ki-leistung es
gibt da eine ganz komplexe Verflechtung
von Mensch und Technologie wie wir es ja
Beispiel des maschinellenlären sehen und
für die Zukunft denke ich auch dass
viele Bereiche durchaus disruptive
ändert werden können du hast schon
angesprochen Kreativität Konzept Design
solche Dinge wer weiß ob es in Zukunft
noch Übersetzerinnen und Übersetzer
braucht ne noch brauchen sie aber sie
werden eine Möglichkeit auch Ärztinnen
und Ärzte Diagnostikerin Diagnostiker
sicherlich bei Dingen wie medizinischen
ja Feststellung sollte man immer noch
ein Mensch dabei haben der dann noch mal
Blick drauf wirft nicht dass das System
sich ändert das ist auch aus ethischer
Sicht problematisch aber man kann die
Dinge sich weiter vorstellen andere
Lebensbereichen KI ist so geschmeidig
und Muster finden wir überall Lebenswelt
das auch KI eigentlich nahezu überall
Obi quitär eingesetzt werden kann ja wow
ja der letzte Punkt vielleicht so oder
ja also einfach wird mich interessieren
wie du das so siehst mit dieser ganzen
Jobsituation weil jetzt haben wir ja
festgestellt durch die Punkte die wir
beschrieben haben und die Beispiele
einerseits kann sowas wie eine mit
journey ai ein unglaublich tolles
Werkzeug dafür sein und dann sagen wir
mal die Fusion um Open Source sozusagen
also diese Technologie kann ein Werkzeug
sein für Leute die kreative Ideen haben
aber nicht malen können das ist ja eine
unglaublich tolle Entwicklung und
gleichzeitig verlieren aber auch andere
Menschen potentiell ihren Job und und da
wäre die Frage für mich also ja passiert
das ist das gut oder schlecht wie siehst
du das ist es vielleicht nicht so in die
Richtung ich weiß nicht also sollten wir
uns vielleicht nicht darüber streiten ob
das überhaupt passiert sondern eher
jetzt uns fragen moralisch auch fragen
wie
wie wie gehen wir mit diesem mit dieser
Transformation um ja also was ist deine
Sichtweise dazu ich denke wir können den
Prozess nicht mehr aufhalten der
künstlichen Intelligenz die hat sich so
bewährt und sie ist auch zu effizient
dass wir auch aus ja ethischen Gründen
wie ich finde nicht darauf verzichten
können wir müssen aber die Entwicklung
immer kritisch begleiten reflexiv
begleiten das bedeutet die Entwicklung
der künstlichen Intelligenz ist kein
Selbstläufer der Eigendynamik entwickelt
ohne kritische Reflexion sondern wir
müssen in jedem Moment schauen wohin
entwickelt sich das sind das
Wünschenswerte Ergebnisse werden dadurch
Menschen zu bloßen Objekten gemacht zu
Objekten die nur zur Datenbasis
beitragen also müssen immer die
menschliche Würde in allen Entwicklung
immer waren immer reflektieren die muss
mehr gelten als die Effizienz der
Systeme aber dieses Thema können auch
dazu beitragen unser Leben zu verbessern
angenehmer zu machen und vielleicht auch
leichter zu machen wie wir in einer
Diskussion über blockchain auch mal ist
besprochen haben ja super Jörg danke dir
für deine Einblicke und die Diskussion
über das Thema wir sehen uns einfach bei
einer nächsten Folge und freue mich
drauf ciao ciao vielen Dank tschüss